[Music]
in YouTube is [ __ ] us news dad's
submitted by Jessica YouTube is now D
monetizing and restricting a ton of our
videos guys JK news is on life support
oh yeah guys we flew under the radar all
these years but now we've been exposed
we're in a tough ass situation and I
want to stay being myself cuz I'm a fake
[ __ ] okay but if we abide by every
single YouTube rule you know what's
gonna happen we're gonna have to turn it
to a [ __ ] children's channel do
you want that do you want I don't want
that yeah we want to stay raw but they
keep D monetizing us which is affecting
our livelihood so we can't keep making
these crazy videos anymore I know can
you imagine Jay King is all censored in
puppies are cute news submitted by dog
lover me the world is adopting more
puppies and it is shown to have more joy
on people
I believe that puppies are just great I
looked at a puppy and smiled mm-hmm I
have two puppies do you guys smile when
you guys come to my house I do I have
before I comes here of it well so a
recent study has shown that puppies 75
percent increase the serotonin inside of
your body and is it still a puppy if
it's four months old yes I think so
my puppy is 7 years old oh and you still
call it a puppy that's cute that's
really cute I'm sorry vited you you can
come over I accept your apology Thanks
hey you guys it's cute because it's
actually not a puppy but you call it a
puppy that's so funny thanks guys
one time I saw my puppies doing
something oh I can't talk about oh that
kind of oh it's that's kind of story
yeah we'll have to go on the patreon yep
yeah
at the point okay we need to open up a
patreon so that we can fight this thing
okay so that hopefully we can keep our
our place as the last bastion for
profanity on YouTube and we don't become
a kids react channel which i think is a
safe place to say [ __ ] that's right
[ __ ] zone or caves or TD burgers yep we
say that here you can't say that on kids
react you know why cuz if I was like did
you cut the part where I said [ __ ] ok
good hang on so yeah guys get excited
because we're gonna be giving you guys
some really exclusive stuff yeah so
we're gonna have one exclusive off the
record every week one exclusive fan
submitted question that we will pick
every week for exclusive a regular JK
news articles that will not be on
YouTube that's 24 exclusive videos on
our patreon that you can see every month
baby every lunar cycle every lunar cycle
that's not every month is it yeah
awesome
keep JK stupid please join our patreon
hell yeah
and thank you guys so much for
supporting us for over seven years and
if you join our patreon you're gonna let
us be able to be our crazy selves shirt
embarrassing stories and go deep and
personal with you guys all right guys
let's not let YouTube scare little
youtube that's like oh no there's all
these people saying bad words as [ __ ]
let's do monetize them even though
they've been making us [ __ ]
money for the last several years this
[ __ ] I'm getting too mad I gotta relax I
gotta [ __ ] relax anyways go to our
patreon right now so you could see all
the information please join us in this
fight against YouTube's censorship
because we need your support we can't do
this without you and please let's let's
just keep the word [ __ ] a line we need
to do this beep [ __ ] alive right now to
the description box [ __ ] sex stories and
stupidity are the soul of this channel
please don't let them take it from us No
[Music]